the mandalorian season two finale is
here
and because this is the finale we're
cutting our reaction up into two parts
this is part one
part two we have end screen cards link
and pink comment in description box
to watch part two after you're done
watching part one as always if you guys
enjoy our video please subscribe and
click that notification bell more
importantly hit that like button as well
per use full length reaction watch along
as we sync it with the time code or all
over
our patreon page this qualifies as
reaction highlights but i do want to
give a special thank you to all have
made this a really great holiday season
by joining our patreon and becoming a
patron of jack because over there we
cover so many shows where at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along included
shows like supernatural doctor who just
continued to tack on titan avatar the
last
airbender a whole bunch of tv shows to
cover over there guarantee you guys
it's worth it lastly gotta thank my
buddy eric over at nerd chronic
for editing this video for us he's
putting a lot of hard work all he asks
that you give him a follow on twitter or
check out his youtube channel he's an
amazing guy thank you eric for all the
hard work you do in the middle of your
busy schedule
all right guys it's been a crazy build
up i rewatched some rebels episodes
yesterday that are all pertaining to the
darksaber because i want it all fresh in
my mind
let's do this
very cool
one day red letter media might notice
one day and they'll be
so pleased they're not going to rib us
or anything
or the exact kind of channel they love
[Laughter]
oh wow it's kicking things off
get him boba get that pershing it's
paint
not polish on the armor
disengage all transponders
like a leviathan is the kid alive
yes he's on the cruiser
calm down guys i'm not with him we can
work something
dedicated to the cause dank ferric
you're gonna wish you never left
alderaan
i saw the tear oh okay i saw your planet
destroyed was he on the death star i was
on the desk
destroying your planet was a small price
to pay
shoot him to rid the galaxy of terrorism
oh right right in the kisser
she should just get that gift for when
she blocks people on twitter
[Laughter]
the last thing you see before no more of
my
the rescue
[Music]
i don't think i'll get i'll ever get
over them being in the same shot
she's back not all mandalorians are
bounty hunters
some of us serve a higher purpose like
trying to rule mandalore i'm off gideon
that's exactly who she's looking for
find him
well i just sent him a message you are
not a mandalorian
never said i was i didn't know sidekicks
were allowed to talk
ooh what about you
you are a disgrace to your armor
this armor belonged to my father don't
you mean your
donor i've heard your voice
thousands of times mine might be the
last one you hear
damn
dude dude
reefs my god showing off the moose
this is not the time to fight gideon has
a weapon that once belonged
it is an ancient weapon that can cut
through anything i will kill them off
and retake what is rightfully mine
i'll do it in your armor help me rescue
the child
and you can have whatever you want he is
my only priority
i love how he just seemed like he used
to it was all about being mandalorian
he's like forget mandalorians i'll take
my helmet off whatever you want this
one's kickback
garrison of dark troopers on board these
are a third generation design
they are no longer suits the human
inside was the final weakness to be
solved
of course phase one lambda shuttle
issues a distress call
costco fennec dune and myself disembark
with maximum initiative
all together we'll meet at the bridge
nice but if if din jaron
fights him off gideon and takes a dark
saber
he could be the leader of the mandalores
yeah
if he wants that power up those shields
princess
i'll put on a good show just be careful
in there
exiting hyperspace look at this it looks
so classic yeah
i don't know who i want to fight moff
gideon more
yarn or bokeh i almost feel like danger
will come across
him first and then bogus hand will
intervene thus ascending to her fight
and allowing him to escape
repeat requesting emergency talking we
are under
attack where we going you're crazy
one a view i love when they managed to
make the tie fighters feel so
imposing yeah
great shot
[Music]
wow
oh dude this feels like such like a
classic star wars movie right now
they've literally rounded up a posse for
this
going under disguise galactic shift
oh this is a great team working together
by stormtroopers
this music it's like a dubstep nightmare
where'd everyone else go damn it
i missed a key part of the plan bother
the misdirection
woman get it done woman get it on
dude oh my god hey
dude
you guys could be a more effective there
they are
stop put your weapons down
oh what a bitching gun oh what a
terrible gun
[Laughter]
yes yes
thanks damn i thought in the last
episode the stormtroopers did all right
man they are not the last two they were
alley for the season but the worst ones
on the ship
okay you know no one's gonna find us
anyway we got the death troopers what do
we need these guys for
no no no jesus christ
oh this is just one oh damn
wow oh my god
what a cut damn
that felt so painful
you just made it scary ah
this noises he's making
oh my god
what do you need a gun for
it really moves like an animatronic yeah
oh nice right in the jugular oh there
you go
this best car sphere yeah buddy
how many refills on those whistling
birds oh
yeah okay
alien that's what's up
dude what a shot oh this is great
this is like your your star wars fantasy
right now it's just
a ton of stars dude dude
oh yes
oh he's probably with grogu right of
course
he knows what the rapture is what if he
finds him off gideon with the best card
he's gonna fight monkey with the best
car steal they wouldn't have brought
that up yeah
i used to belong to bo katan oh man
i know you've been traveling with boca
tan seeking me or
more accurately this
oh he's so good i'm not there
and now they're beginning to back oh my
god okay
i just want the kid
very well he seems so caught off guard
by that i know right
never trust an imperial trust an isb
dude whoa whoa
whoa we're getting live action dark
saber action
no we're doing this
yes so
good that he got that spear in that suit
of armor
nice
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
man
that's the end of part one people you
can click that end screen card pin
comment link in the description box to
go watch part two and you're gonna want
to
[Music]